When you first start out,
having never created a game before,
it feels like there's a bunch of stuff
you don't know, you're not doing right,
it's not working out, but games
are really like other forms of art.
You use the skills you have to
create something for yourself, and
then you decide when and
if you want to share it with others.
Some people are comfortable
putting their raw work in progress
right out there.
Others work privately for years
before publishing their first game.
As you learn more about how to make
games and you get better at it.
The games you create just naturally
tend to become more sophisticated.
Maybe you start with really
rudimentary bad guys, but
then you figure out how to do AI or
pathfinding.
Or maybe at the beginning,
you do all your own artwork,
even though you're not really an artist.
While later on, you might collaborate
with someone who really knows what
they're doing and can contribute
amazing art direction to your project.
But hey there's nothing
wrong with program work.
Regardless of how big or complex though
the best games you'll ever write are the
ones that you think are fun the play.
And you can make a fun game no matter
how little experience you have so
don't get too hung up on
doing it the right way or
being an expert on everything
related to game development.
It's more important that you
just keep building games.
You'll learn what you need
to know as you go along,
and eventually it will
all make perfect sense.